[Music]
you've been running interference on a
really bad person for a long time is
that fair it is it is but people think
he's very nice does it hey doesn't
matter what they think behind closed
doors in people's homes is almost always
different
[Music]
errata
this is john with the dr john deloney
show
talk about mental health and wellness
and relationships in schools and
education and life
time and love and tenderness that's my
only michael bolton reference of the day
i hope you're doing well and hope your
family's doing well
whoo so glad you're here um we've got a
lot going on today so i'm just going to
jump right into
the calls
i'm going to stop the shenanigans and
just get them rocking and rolling let's
go to ann out in dallas texas what's up
anne
hi john thank you so much for taking my
call thank you are you kidding thank you
for calling back it means the world to
me ann thank you so much thank you i
listen to you all the time and the more
i listen to you this is why i asked you
on on facebook
um and i'm so thankful that you're
taking my call
um the more i listen to you the more
i've learned so much from you
um
let me just
i'm 63 years old okay i've been a
homemaker for many many years
i've been through abuse in my marriage
okay so it's my second marriage i've
been married before for five years in my
teens
so with that background i didn't want to
go through another divorce
so i married my husband i thought he was
wonderful
and
i put up with abuse i had three more
children i have four
i have three more children
i stayed at home raising them
and now i feel all my kids are grown and
gone i have grandchildren now and it
just hit me
um
i feel
if i could have redo's i would redo i
feel the more i'm hearing you and the
more i'm reading
and reading god's word the more i know
that we shouldn't have put up with abuse
we can't control others like i always
hear you say you can't control anyone
but yourself
and i've been trying to
change my husband to
have more value for me
and
i've allowed abuse and no connection and
lies
and i know i've done that and i have
regrets
how do i do how do i
get i have your book in front of me i
just got it in the mail
how do i
own my past and change my future wow
because
and that's so much um
mm-hmm it's a lot well 34 years of
marriage
are y'all are y'all still married
we're still married but legally only
okay we we are not together um
pardon me in the same home we share a
home
but it's he knows only because we were
building a home
after we started building a home he
broke my fingers
i would have left him right then and
there
my son was gonna be married the next day
we were putting on a dinner in two hours
so i didn't know what to do
so after the wedding i i had my hand was
in a cast and everything
how did you break your fingers
he grabbed him he got angry grabbed him
and crunched him what a scumbag dude i
called i caught him in a lie it was with
another woman um flirting with another
woman and i and i he felt cornered
because i said just tell the truth
because he would lie to me all the time
and he left us he left the kids and i in
their teen years for four years i was
foolish enough to get back with him hey
hold on one second hold on a second hold
on a second
okay
somebody somewhere along the way and
told you that there's something wrong
with you
and somebody along the way told you that
you're dumb
and somebody along the way told you
like
the difference like dumb is you don't
have the right information in your head
and somebody else told you you're an
idiot
you're a sucker
and i don't think that at all
and those people who told you that
have informed over time the story that
you have begun to tell yourself
and so before we go any further
you're not dumb and you're not an idiot
you survived
you're we're abused did you stay yes you
did
you stayed alive
you stayed fed
you stayed in a warm place
and you're not dumb and you're not less
than and you didn't fail
okay
okay okay
thank you
i i the
we could probably go back to you or
seven and just
spend several hours together i'd love to
hear your story i can tell you in just a
few minutes of talking to you that you
are
incredibly compassionate and kind and
thoughtful
and that you've been running
interference on a really
bad person for a long time is that fair
it is it is but people think he's very
nice does it hey doesn't matter what
they think
behind closed doors in people's homes is
almost always different
it is right
and when that happens you end up looking
and feeling crazy because people come
tell you over the last 30 years what a
great guy and oh my gosh like you're so
lucky
and there's part of you that thinks oh
it's probably me
and then he breaks your hand in a
grown-up
temper tantrum and somehow you work that
into
the stories converge in your mind in the
land
well i just
i'm just gonna get through this and then
i'm gonna get through that and then i
just need to suck it up and buckle up
here and i'm just gonna make sure you
see what i'm saying and all of a sudden
you land right back in the same place
i did my son's wedding was the next date
and i thought what are they gonna do
yeah
what would have been awesome and this is
this is awesome as an outsider right not
this would have been terrible for your
family would have been awesome
if dad had missed the funeral because
his butt was in jail
right right now before breaking the
bones of an extraordinary 60 year old
woman that would have been awesome
and that would have been absent from all
photos all pictures all memories that
have been fantastic didn't happen that
way that's cool get that
um ultimately
here we are
and so my question for you is
what do you want to do
because you've done i mean you've owned
the past
probably too much
you have
taken all those bricks in your backpack
over the last several years i'm guessing
and you have looked at them and examined
them and you've come to say whoa whoa
whoa i'm worth more than this i always
have been
and so what i got married when i was a
child and it didn't work out
it doesn't mean i was destined or
required to have a life of
abuse and infidelity and anger and rage
and protecting my kid like
i'm worth more than this
the challenge is
you've taken the bricks out of your
backpack but you're still holding them
all
you haven't set them down
well i don't want my kids i didn't want
to raise my kids without a father i
would hear i was raised on dr dobson
and he said you don't it's worse to
to raise them without a father
so i kept hanging on to that because i'd
listen to dr dobson all the time so
i'm not going to speak of dr dobson okay
i don't know enough about it and that
was before
what i will tell you is
anybody who tells you it's better to
stay in an abusive relationship where
mom is being beat up cheated on yelled
at excluded
that's better
than not having a man in the house is
should not have a microphone
they're insane
okay
so how do i go from here yeah that okay
so that's important so let's we'll
toggle
to
here's like
i think regret is important
but it's got a really short shelf life
to it it's like wasabi right eating it
like if you go get sushi and eat wasabi
it burns like fire real for a second and
then all of a sudden it's just gone
right
that's regret
you look back and go man i wish i could
have done that over
and then really quick you come to right
now
because you can't you can't most people
get stuck in the i wish i should have
just i should have just done it all
differently and here here i am
shouldn't have gained this much weight
over the last 10 years and i'm 100
pounds overweight just is what it is i'm
just going to bad whatever
and then we have you have to ask
yourself the terrifying scary brave next
question which is what i want next
i want free
yeah
i want free
so here's my here's my here's my
response to that number one
and hear me say this directly as i can
you deserve to be free and i never ever
tell somebody
to get divorced
you need to get away from a man who's
breaking your bones and cheating on you
today
okay and here's the other thing i know
too
okay i've read the data for too long
and women who leave abusive
relationships end up on the street
because they got no place to go
and so my question is where would you go
do you have a family a child that you
could move in with do you have
and i'm not talking about for two weeks
i'm talking about for six months
do you have money saved that you could
or have access to
okay i have money you could go in an
apartment and stay right do you have a
place to go you have
four walls is the way we say it here is
you have food transportation clothing
and
um home like with your you know your
home and your utilities things like that
yes there's about
there we were building a house and the
in
the builder didn't finish it and so we
were in the lawsuit we we sued him which
we'd never sued anybody but anyway we're
done
well we're trying to get just cut our
ties and lose it but now we so we have
about
it'll be about 800 000
is what
what we will have after
the house is sold
so
um what you're gonna need to do is get
an attorney
okay to walk alongside you otherwise
that money goes in his pocket and you
end up destitute and it happens too okay
okay so you get an attorney that will
walk alongside you
okay and you get a couple of girlfriends
that will walk alongside you that you
can tell everything to and that you
trust
and that you can say
here's what's been going on in my home
have you ever done that
i have i have okay and um
have you gotten burned
i did
um
this one person i trusted and i would
trust her with anything
they did something her and her family
being a christian that i didn't agree
with that it was against god's word okay
um so you i heard you and dave on the
show the other just the other day
saying you go you gotta make friends you
gotta make friends she was my best
friend for 37 years yeah
and i had to let it go
just
and we're not that close anymore because
i called her out on it okay so what
whatever whatever value violation
happened it happened
okay your next hard work is to get new
friends
okay okay it's just got to be a part of
a thing and it might be for a season
you're gonna pay a therapist to go sit
with in fact i would a thousand percent
recommend the two places you need to
spend money is you need an attorney and
you need to get a counselor
okay okay okay
and
expect the freedom to come at a price
both a
true like a real price and this will be
scary because this is what you have
known for so long
and so hear me say this i want these
words to rattle around in your soul let
them park there
okay you're worth a home
you're worth being loved
nobody has any business putting their
hands on you ever ever
no one has any business telling you that
you're anything other than wonderful
okay
ever
you're worth somebody not cheating on
you
wondering where somebody's been and what
diseases you're getting in your own
house
all of that
sounds like before you even called
you're ready
i'm ready i'm ready i i was ready the
day he broke my hands
yes and i was in a therapy for a year i
felt stuck because of this house
situation
and i'm not stuck anymore i don't i'll
yeah i'm not stuck anymore if you reach
out to one of your kids would they take
you in for a season
um
yes but i don't want to do that so i do
have money i can't i know i know hold on
hold on it might be a great great great
gift to your kids
oh
okay
and when
this happens they've seen this for years
right they've watched this
have they talked to you about it before
my daughter i have two boys and one girl
okay and my daughter says mom
i'm really angry why you never left him
years ago okay
my two boys
oh mom you know dad oh mom
so they make excuses for their dad it's
bull crap dude that's how that crap
rolls downhill and they're gonna do it
to their kids and on and on and on and
on right mm-hmm
it's gotta stop it has to stop so i'd
call your daughter and by the way when
she says stuff like that that's her
working out her pain okay
um and that's that's
take that with a grain of salt okay
okay um
she's working through her stuff too i'd
call her and say today's the day it's
time can i come stay with you for a few
weeks will you help me find an apartment
will you help me set up my bills and the
internet and the electricity and those
kind of things will you help me get my
own cell phone plan will help me get car
insurance all those little nicknacky
things that may have just happened you
may have been doing this for years but
it's all the knick-knack stuff it's like
oh i don't even know where my
oh i can do it i i handled everything so
that's all
i did i i got all the stuff okay
call your daughter and
walk walk her through this too she's
safe okay
and if she offers mom i want you to come
stay with us
give her that gift
and at the same time you'll be giving
yourself the gift too
if she says well where are you gonna go
you got an apartment then that might be
her saying and maybe not mine maybe not
my house and you can say great i'm ready
i'm ann and i'm rich hey she just had a
baby but it might be awesome if you were
there to hold that baby too
okay okay
because that would be lovely
fancy
for me that would be wonderful well and
here's the thing i'm trying to trick you
it would be a gift for her
but it would be therapeutic and healing
for you
because you're going to go to your own
apartment and you're going to get really
really lonely
and i think it's been a long time since
i looked at it
is it kelly me was it seven times people
go back to an abusive relationship
before they leave
before they leave finally
because they go away and they get lonely
and they get scared and they get quiet
and then they go back and then they go
back and then
add a loneliness
so i want you to have people in your
life well sometimes they go back because
they're just hungry they don't have
money right i mean these are like basic
things it's easy to say yeah you should
just march on out of there but for
millions and millions of women the
question is okay where where do i eat
and so let's have money
good good good you probably want to put
your own account all here's the deal all
that stuff your attorney's going to walk
you through okay okay and your counselor
will walk you through so i'll stop
giving you tips i'm just throwing stuff
at you now hear me say
you're worth more than this nonsense
thank you okay you're right it happened
young it did happen young it did and
you've carried this story with you for a
long long time and it's time to set that
story down and here's the deal you spent
a ton of energy 30 plus years of energy
trying to go back and edit a story that
has already happened
stop trying to edit that story and spend
all of the rest of your precious
thought and brilliance and grit and
determination
and write something new what comes next
okay okay
okay will you do that you're coming to
dallas yes yes john and you're gonna
come to dallas i'm gonna go see you all
i'll be in i'll be in dallas in the fall
and um yes i look forward to seeing you
thank you cool
that's great and then as far as a job
like
okay
okay i do have money but do i get a job
you will need a job yes
um for multiple reasons
that's not priority number one
okay if you've i've talked to people who
i've got to get a job today because i'm
i don't have any like i'll have no money
you're not in that situation it will you
will have to sit down with the financial
advisor at some point and walk through
okay what's the rest of my life look
like
and um that's fine that's that's part of
it that's cool
okay you'll figure that part out as you
go um right now it's being safe and
you're not safe
you're stuck
you've got somebody you
you've got a a bear a rhinoceros
sleeping in the bed next to you
who just gets mad and breaks your bones
[Music]
god that rages me out so much
and i'm so grateful for you
[Music]
almost say something's gonna get me in
trouble i'm just gonna go to break and
we love you keep us in touch and let us
know how we're doing we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible
and they'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back hey uh i got my
breath after that last call
listen we are on the road um for book
tour meeting making stops across the
country and
listen
the number of people who came up that
this show has created its own
universe
and the number of people who came up and
dropped inside jokes and were asking
about private thing like hey how's
kelly's kids doing and how's you know
all right did james kids get their
bonnets fixed um on the covered wagon
excursion they were on did jon how was
your like they were sorry i was just
banging on james um but they were asking
like you guys you guys listen to the
show
i i
all of us kept going back to the to the
car and we're heading back to the hotel
was like hey this show is bigger than we
thought not and the metrics are huge and
all that's great it's different y'all
are walking with us in this thing and
i'm so grateful so please don't forget
to send this show to your friends that
you that you care about
or maybe the ones that you don't like um
your family members send this show off
we're really grateful when you do and
the impact it's having is the ripple
effects are just extraordinary and it's
not because of me it's for sure not
because of james and kelly it's because
of you
y'all are going home and you're
internalizing some of the stuff you're
asking having hard conversa
conversations at home um you're deciding
to
to get with a counselor you're deciding
to tell your wife i am sorry you're
deciding to sell your husband i want our
lives to be better
y'all are doing hard work you all are
doing tough tough stuff and you're
making things different for your kids
and for grandkids that you've never even
met yet
it's i'm grateful thanks for walking
with us make sure you share the show
we're really really grateful all right
let's go out to elizabeth in roanoke
virginia what's up e-money how we doing
hey to dr john it's an honor to speak
with you it is more of an honor for me
to talk to you so what's up
so i'm calling today because i am really
conflicted about my marijuana use
and so i've been using marijuana daily
for about eight years and at the
beginning of this year i decided to quit
but i quickly discovered it was much
more difficult
but elizabeth you can't get addicted to
weed
well that was me being an idiot you
should for sure can i don't even know
where they're going get where that came
from but okay so so watch me start
trying to come to terms with that
hey
f coming to terms with an addiction is
the worst right it's the worst so why'd
you want to quit why'd you want to stop
so my husband and i decided that we
wanted to try to have children so this
was in order to get pregnant and then
the first month that i didn't get
pregnant i just resumed right back to
daily use essentially why and now i have
this big conflict really why because i
feel like life is too difficult to
manage there you go it's hard for me to
be
alive and sober
why
i have a really hard time with being
uncomfortable
and so being able to to smoke
weed just like turns off my brain at the
end of the night yeah for sure otherwise
i get in that fury um what else do i
need to do what other chores are there
should i be doing more it kind of goes
into
um not being able to relax and just be
okay with relaxing just be
where where did that
um story come from
like when did you discover about
yourself that the world was just hard
um
i've seen actually more recently because
before but i mean you've spoken for a
decade now right
pretty much yeah okay so at some point
it started
[Music]
ago my husband and i quit drinking
completely because we were
did not have a healthy relationship with
alcohol
so really i think back all the way to
before i stopped drinking i started
which was like 13 years old yep and at
that time i was dealing with depression
okay
which i still do continue to deal with
depression on and off sure um
so what was what was going on at home
i think a lot of
not being heard okay that's really a big
theme that comes up for me is not being
heard okay
what was going on in place of you being
not heard
everything else
i think i learned early on that i just
needed to take care of myself
who taught you that
um
that was something i assumed myself i
think because i wasn't getting what i
needed at home at an early age so i just
stepped up and started doing that for
myself where were mom and dad
uh president but busy my my father
traveled for work a lot so he might be
gone for like a week at a time and my
mom was stay-at-home mom but emotionally
psychologically not very present she's
very task oriented too okay
so
um
i'm interested what do you think i'm
gonna say about marijuana
i think you will tell me
some of the hazards but i'm in therapy
now and i've been talking about this
dilemma for about the past two months
and my therapist is so gracious telling
me the hazards of it
um but i just feel like i'm
really split i'm really on the fence so
i know but you like so what do you so
you think i'm just going to tell you the
hazards of it
um
i think that that's a piece of it
but i'm not quite sure all right so
get what what's your conflict
my conflict is on one hand i feel like
my life would improve if i didn't use
marijuana how improve how would it
improve
i think it probably affects my sleep to
sleep and energy one thousand percent
the research is super clear that it's
sleep disruptive
okay so
sleep all right what else would it would
improve
i think i would actually be able to
pursue things that i'm interested in
rather than kind of using half of my day
to veg out and do nothing okay
what else
um
i think my health would obviously
improve so even with smoking like i get
i get a wheeze in my lungs and i'll just
like take an inhaler and then just go
back to smoking yeah i know that that's
incongruent who i want to be okay
oh gosh what you have been in counseling
using words like in congruence way to go
all right so i wanted to be a mental
health counselor but let's see you know
all the stuff right well the knowing and
doing they're not just exactly okay so
you've
you've been down the road um
there's something bigger driving this
you're not having you're not thinking
about making a
what i would call an intimate behavior
change this is a big deal
because this has
this has been your buffer between you
and a very dangerous world for almost 10
years
and it's probably been a buffer between
you and a somewhat tumultuous marriage
and it's been a buffer between you and a
very disregulated
brain
that's that's
hyper vigilant wondering why does nobody
find value in me
tell me i'm wrong
listen to you like i don't know maybe
so
like
you don't just give that up
you don't just give up a warm jacket or
a coat that you wear in the winter that
keeps you warm
there's a reason why and it's below like
well i just want to sleep better and
accomplish a few things
what's the real reason you're done with
this
are you you're considering being done
with it
um
i do think it holds me back i don't
think i'm living up to my full potential
okay
and and i use it as a coping mechanism
yeah so i i do self-medicate for
depression with marijuana
and it's really hard it's really scary
to give that up yeah it's your feeling
yep um
what has your mental health counselor
told you that like what if what have
they advised you
well she's been really great in staying
with me and ambivalent
so i don't feel like i've gotten any
kind of direction in any way but
honestly that's actually probably right
what i need okay um because i feel like
i could i could become defensive if i
get pushed either way if you called me
for ambivalence you may have made the
wrong phone call
i'm not good with anybody
for the honest truth oh gotcha okay
all right so here's here's the
here's the honest truth
weed works
most of the time it works
it helps put a buffer between people in
the world
and not everybody some people make some
super all all this stuff we all know
that
um i think in what's happened in the
past 10 to 15 years 25 years
is there has been such a mania around it
that every people on both sides of the
equation have lost their minds
there's those who are willing to look at
a 65 year old going through stage 4
cancer chemo
and say nope you don't get to have pain
reduction you have to take opioids that
are going to prescribe to you that are
going to decimate your community ready
go
and then there's the others who are like
you know what my 14 year old's a little
bit wacky a little bit spun up let's
give him marijuana because there's
absolutely no right both sides are nuts
okay
and so here's the honest truth that i've
seen over the last 20 years of working
with people
it works
and
ultimately in a situation like yours in
it will take everything
right
that's how it feels sometimes it does it
does and it has
and you've it it's that weird the the
colder it gets outside the less the
harder it is to get the jacket up
and the only way to finally face the
demons is to be out in the cold for a
season
and it's not long season
but it's a i've it's not just a matter
of you quitting smoking weed it means i
have to get really serious about my
childhood
i gotta get real serious about my
depression
i gotta get super hyper focused about
how i live my life
i'm gonna have to have some hard
conversations in my marriage right so
it's not just quitting weed
it's are you ready to change almost
everything
that's i think the dilemma because i am
assuming that that's the package deal
and it's really hard to move forward
knowing that i'm going to be feeling
uncomfortable going through this process
of being cold without the jacket and
also learning new skills as i go
if it feels
i've never done anything like i guess
that challenging
it feels really difficult can i tell you
something i think you have
i think you've survived
i don't think you're telling me the full
picture of your childhood and i don't
blame you so that's totally cool
i think you've seen some stuff
and i think you've put up with a lot of
stuff
fair
yeah
talk all the way into your phone for me
i've put up with a lot yeah that's fair
and
i think you have done hard stuff for a
long time i don't think you realize how
strong you are
and
you know how bad it's going to be for a
while
the research tells us is about two weeks
of absolute bloody hell when you become
the worst version of yourself
if you quit cold turkey today it would
be two to three weeks of misery
sleep dysregulated anxiety exhausted it
sounds it's awful there's no i mean
there's no way to walk through it i mean
there's no other way to walk through it
um in fact one one study i was looking
at recently suggest like there's not
even there's not even
that that anybody knows of um in the
study i was looking at um
there was medication to softland this
didn't work
because
again we're talking about you've got
this stuff works for a reason and you
got to turn and face the stuff that it's
protecting you from
i don't feel like i have a plan to
to deal with that so like how do you
live for those two weeks
but what do you
like i don't know how to do that
the way forward through those two weeks
is twofold number one you let your
counselor know i'm about to do this and
let's get a game plan in place
number two
you be hyper intentional about knowing
this too shall pass
i'm gonna commit for 30 days that's it
i'm gonna commit for 30 days to not use
full stop
i might eat i might go work out i might
just
kick and scream on my couch whatever
um it usually helps if you change the
environment so we're also gonna cut out
netflix we're gonna take away the normal
things we do
as a routine
so that this thing that ball doesn't get
rolling down the hill without even me
even realizing it
you know what i mean
like there's just a routine i get home
and i drop my keys here and i turn the
tv on there and all of a sudden i'm
packing a bull and i don't even realize
it
right it just happened like so i'm gonna
disrupt that thing all the way to i'm
gonna drive home a different way home
from work
i'm gonna park in the street for 30 days
instead of the garage i'm gonna i'm
gonna disrupt that that cycle
and i'm gonna be vigilant about it and
here the important part for me when i've
tried to break addictions and i've never
been addicted to marijuana but when i've
had to change behaviors is i get really
intentional about what's setting it off
what is making me want to go hide
why am i keep like for me like why why
do i keep reaching for food
and what i noticed in short order was
super annoying is when i was tired or
when i got had work stress or i had
relationship
when i was out of whack with my family
my kid would come in and say hey i can't
believe you said this and i'm like
whatever and as i'm reaching for the bag
of cookies like it just it was automated
or i'd get home and i'd feel some
tension on my wife and i would just feel
it and be like i don't feel like having
a discussion today and i'm just grabbing
the gummy worms
you see what i'm saying it's like so i
became i carried something around with
me and i write what
what is my body trying to protect me
from right now
and it's just gonna be miserable
for a couple of weeks
and on the other side of it
is sleep like you haven't slept in 10
years or 15 years or 20 years
and what's on the other side of it is
like a cataract getting pulled off your
eyes and peace
and laughter
not
high laughter but like that's actually
really funny laughter
you know what i mean
no but i hear you i haven't had it i
mean so
so
or i'm just using your words like
accomplishment
yeah
nothing worthy of being accomplished
happens easy
comes at a price it's hard
and going all the way back to your
original like man i just i don't like
being uncomfortable that's what we're
gonna practice
but i will tell you this for as long as
you smoked i want you to have contact
with a professional whether it's your
mental health counselor whether you get
with a doctor and let them know i want
you to have somebody with you that you
can call okay
okay
and it will walk alongside you um
before i let you go what
what scares you the most about this
feeling feel my feelings i think
that is the scariest part who told you
your feelings were weren't valuable what
were they
um
i think it's just the messages of like
that not being heard young
but now more recently like you know if i
were not smoked today or the days that
i've been trying
i'm very uncomfortable i hate
the feelings that i have i'm an agitator
tell me about it
what are they what what's what's the
feelings
usually like more of an agitation and
that that's really difficult for me to
handle okay what do you get agitated
ah there you go i feel i feel just
uncomfortable i'm agitated that i'm not
high i guess yeah no no no no it's it's
it's
man i'm heartbroken for you because
after many years and lots of experiences
and lots of stories
it's become uncomfortable to live in
your own skin
because you don't think you're worthy of
your space and and
on this side of use you won't hear me on
the on the other side you will you're
worthy of your space
and you're worthy of peace
and your feelings count
even your agitated ones even your
annoying ones even your uncomfortable
ones they all count
and then you gotta go make the next
right hard decision
will you say that i'm worth
not being high
i'm worth not being high
are you worth
wrestling with your depression for the
first time for real
yeah i'm worth
dealing with this depression
are you worth a really good marriage
i'm worth a really good marriage okay
hey takes a lot of courage and a lot of
bravery to look up on ten-year-old
patterns and say i want to i want to be
different
i'm really does i'm proud of you that's
hard
and anybody that tells you there's an
easy path is trying to sell you snake
oil
they're lying they're lying to you
okay okay
um
will your husband join you on this
yeah he's really ambivalent as well it's
recorded right in the same turning point
right now okay
um i want you to check out a book it's
called dopamine nation by anna lemke
l-a-m-b-k-e
okay and um
it's less it's a she's the addiction um
she's had the director of addiction
studies at stanford medical school so
she's
about a thousand ex smarter than me
um but it'll give you some really really
concrete practical tools
for disrupting for disregulating these
patterns
but ultimately
there's going to be a season of two to
three weeks of really intense discomfort
followed by an exhaustion followed by a
what do i do now
okay okay
and let me hear you say i mean let me
tell you you're worth it
he's worth it your marriage is worth it
all of it's worth it and the little
knucklehead of kids you're gonna have
down the road they're worth it too
okay right
that fear
yeah all right have this conversation
with your um
with your counselor or with your doctor
to make sure everybody's on the same
plan all of your critical care people in
your life are on the same plan
go with your husband y'all co-create
this plan get that book and y'all can
use it as as as marching orders man and
listen i'm real real proud of you in 30
days when you're done when you've gone
30-day stone
stone clean
holler at me
can't wait to have you back on the show
we'll be right back
all right hey i'm right back in uh hold
on hey elizabeth
are you still there
yes so
this is awesome so i ended the call with
when you're 30 days uh stone
uh
and i was saying like i was trying to
say like stone cleaned clean huh
but in the booth it sounded like i said
after 30 days you're stoned then just
give me a call back that's not what i
meant you know what i meant okay did you
know what i meant i know i knew what you
meant and i was laughing that was kind
of wrong choice of words it couldn't
have been it could have been a worse
choice of words what an idiot so listen
yeah
i was trying to say stone sober that's
what i was looking for
i'm just gonna take all rock and stone
references out and we'll just say this
in 30 days
when you've had 30 days of sobriety hold
her batgirl at me and then we'll
chitchat is that cool
okay that's cool
all right oh my gosh you know what i
should not have for a job is being a
podcaster
oh my goodness all right we'll be right
back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on a camera if you don't want
to it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 percent off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to dallin
in tampa florida what's up my man dallin
hey how's it going we're just rocking on
dude
talking about all kind of crazy things
today what are you up to
oh just uh
gearing up for this call and before we
get going i just i wanted to say thanks
for doing what you do man you add a lot
of clarity and goodness to the world so
like i really appreciate what you do we
need it i'm grateful for you man thank
you so what's up dude
so
i
was
i was trying to figure out some things
that are
a bit complicated emotionally for me so
i i feel like i can't quite see the
force through the trees to
to
make sense of all this
and uh so
feel free to interject and ask questions
if this doesn't have any sort of
cohesive statement to it but um so my
cohesive statements aren't really my
specialty but i'll do my best
right
i appreciate that
uh
so my my dad's currently in jail and has
been for about a year uh what happened
he
well so
uh according to the law i think he had
multiple duis uh to the like felony
level okay so
he had all those
that had to get figured out and from
what i understand he'll be out
in like six months or so
and
i haven't been really good with setting
boundaries with him in the past
mostly
and in the past i mean the more recent
past mostly because
i can't decipher what is true and what
is not and i know enough to know that
a lot of what he's telling me isn't true
but i think he he believes it
i i suspect that he has been misusing a
prescription drugs off and on for the
past 20 years or so
and
my parents divorced when i was really
young when i was nine it was in court
until i was 18. i had a therapist as a
kid and and a guardian that light them
and things were kind of wild back then
but it honestly it it
kind of helped me grow up and taught me
a lot but
at the time my dad claimed that my mom
was diagnosed with bipolar or sorry with
borderline personality disorder and
but i don't know if i can even believe
that and she definitely had all the
earmarks of that from what i've studied
and it makes sense
and my dad seemed to be the same one he
was really smart really well to do in
his career he was doing you know
marathons and just really
an awesome person everyone loved him
and
now
fast forward 20 years and
my mom has become the more stable one my
dad has gone off the rails and so
i tend to not give my mom as much grace
as i should because we have there's a
lot we need to work through
and i i always give my dad the benefit
of the doubt because you know he helped
me out as a kid so much um being
relatively stable
and uh but now like i don't even know
what to believe and i don't know how to
set a boundary or even decide what the
boundary is i mean i've got a
family i've got a wife and three kids
and one on the way so we're
you know we need to have our own
space from
from that craziness um and uh he's
he's been in trouble with the law
multiple times and so let me
this feels busier than it really is
okay so i'm super i'm super glad that
you called
and your dad's in jail so it's a
sensational version but
millions of people
are wrestling with how do i set these
boundaries
and so let me say a couple things these
may have been said to you they should
have been but if they haven't been
your parents divorce had nothing to do
with you
right right
yes
your mom had challenges and your dad had
challenges and they should have
treated you differently and they didn't
and i'm
sorry thanks
you cannot
go back and it's a complete waste of
your time the energy to go reverse
diagnose your mom
and try to quote unquote figure out what
happened it's an equal waste of time to
try to figure out
what your dad is trying to is he telling
the truth is he not is today a good day
is today not a good day
because what you're doing is you're
waiting on external factors to set your
personal and familial boundaries
and that's not how boundaries work
you set your boundaries what does that
mean
if you're going to be intoxicated you
will not be at this home period if you
are using this season we're not going to
have you around i don't care if you
if i feel uncomfortable around you i'm
i'm not i'm going to do
holidays this way this year
right because i can't even tell he's so
functional with it a lot of the time
okay but you don't want him around why
don't you want him around
to i don't trust
that that's it he's just yeah he's too
unpredictable so let me be sometimes
it's great sometimes just not let me be
super clear the only thing you owe him
on planet earth is respect and dignity
period okay you don't owe him your time
you don't owe him access to your kids
you don't owe him a a bed in your home
if you don't want me you don't owe him
you do have to not be a jerk you've got
to be respectful because that's just
human dignity right
um
if you start treating him with
a lack of dignity and respect
that's hurting you not him
right well it hurts him but it hurts you
worse other than that you don't owe him
and you're trying to figure out a way to
keep your kids safe
and to
keep you your
keep your status as his son safe
and at the same time deal with a pinball
machine
right just quit just quit
so so
part of me has toyed with the idea of
like do i just not
engage with them until and i
at all anymore because it's such a i
don't know if it's hot or cold i mean he
gets really delusional too to the point
where he's like they're after me they've
been like it's
bonkers and i'm like i can't go down
that road with you and then he's like oh
you betrayed me for not believing me
you're one of them right and i'm like i
just i can't like i just i feel terrible
just cutting him off and being like i'm
not gonna have a relationship with you
until you normalize and he's like but i
am normal hey listen you're gonna feel
terrible the other way
so the question is not how do i not feel
terrible you feel terrible on both ends
the question is
am i going to choose guilt or am i going
to choose resentment
am i going to choose guilt over
i'm going to feel guilty when he says
you betrayed me you're one of the alien
finders and i bet you you have a secret
bunker in the bottom of the denver
airport right you're gonna feel guilty
there
or
you're going to resent the fact that
he's sitting on your couch high
he hasn't bathed in a couple of days and
he's given some nonsense to your oldest
kid and he's disrespecting your wife
and that's the thing is it's the
opposite he seems like the most
professional
like businessman ever and it's so like
it plays with my mind and i'm like wait
no okay hold on that's not real that
you're done
be done be done
be done yeah
you have permission but i love him right
and i wanna like those aren't mutually
exclusive man they're both in that's
true
i can love you i have some of my best
friends on the planet who i love deeply
i would never hire them
they're
wildly unreliable people when it comes
to like professional stuff if i were to
call and be like all right listen
i'm locked in a studio this guy named
james is trying to kill me they would be
like hang on
one of them i don't even think is
legally allowed to drive but they'd be
like i'm going to get a bus pass and
then it's on give me 18 hours right
they'd come they'd show up would i hire
them no chance right so it's not
mutually exclusive you love your dad and
he is not coming to my home
i love my dad and i care about my dad
and i'm putting in boundaries to keep
him and me safe and him and my wife and
my kids safe
so how how would i
proceed moving forward with the
relationship in any way or is it just
like we're not even talking anymore
you're done why do you
when did it become your job to preserve
your relationship with your dad
i'll tell you when when you were a
seven-year-old kid wondering what you
did to screw up your family
that's why i started this whole thing
with it's not your fault
because you still are trying to duct
tape this thing together man
and you are the kid it's not your job
it's your dad's job to come across the
aisle and hold your face and say i
freaking love you
and my life doesn't work when you're not
in it
and your dad didn't do that
well he yeah maybe he did and he's not
now he did that well and he still tries
to right
he
he almost overdoes it to the point where
i'm like okay i got it dad i got it i
get it you love me right but
and then i'm like but you got to stop
like messing around with prescription
drugs you gotta like be clean of that
and he's like no i am i'm doing what the
doctors say i'm like i don't believe you
yeah
you know until it's like
hey let's let's take another track get
out of the the conversations
look at actions and behavior that's it
behavior is a language
so i don't care what you're saying i
don't care how i i just all i care is i
think you're high i would like you to
not be at my house
yeah
full stop
and if he chooses to not be in
relationship with you because of your
boundaries that's a choice he's made
that's not on you
right
if you say i will not let you around me
or my kids when you're high or when
you're intoxicated
um
and he's like well screw you you're one
of them then he has looked at his son
and said i would rather choose x over
you
yeah that's hard that's hard
all right
right and if everything seems normal and
the actions are starting to sound
relatively leveled after all of this
is there a way to walk back into that or
i think so
yeah and man all right because the
caveat to that is he got married right
before he went to jail yeah and uh
she what are you doing
what's your ultimate goal man what's
your ultimate aim here
i i would love for
i would love to have him stabilize a
little bit on that and then
be able to have the good parts of our
relationship and not the ones that get
delusional um because when we whenever
we interact
and it's not
off you know in
the other land
all of a sudden it's like hey we have a
good relationship
my kids love him right
their favorite grandparent right and
they talk about him all the time and
they wanna
you know he'll send gifts and stuff and
he's just when he's here he'll get down
on his knees with them and play with
them and he just is super present and
it's great
but then also
there's a giant government conspiracy
specifically against him because and he
has this elaborate backstory and i'm
like i can't participate in that
okay if you can't participate it that's
the boundary you're drawing then draw it
and hold it and move on with your life
dude
like you're spending too much time
second guessing your boundaries
yeah and i
i think a lot of it is because i i give
him so much
benefit of the doubt when i'm like okay
well okay i see what you mean maybe
that's a little believable that
you know you were hey that's that's yeah
that's you know what
is the 12 old you still trying to be
like well okay
here here's here's a an outrageous
example what you're describing to me is
exactly the conversation i have when
somebody's in an abusive relationship
right he only listen he only listen he
only hits me when he's really been
drinking and it's fine
usually it's prob like i press it i push
it
like i complain and i get to whine and
then he gets mad so
if i would just shut up then he wouldn't
hit me
and most of the time it's fine and
actually you know what else he's so good
with my my dogs they love him and
they're so good at character judgment
you see what i'm saying point taken yeah
so you can create a here's there's two
fantasies going on one the fantasy of
the perfect family of dad coming back
and being that's not real man
yeah it's not real so you got to live in
reality
yep and the other fantasy is you can
have it all
you can somehow keep the awesome cool
roller on the floor
and then the guy who is an addict and
not safe
right and you can't do both
or you can but you've got to have some
comically strong um
really strong boundaries and some really
strong implementation guidelines and a
really respectful person who's going to
hear your boundaries and go all right
time to go and i'm going to walk out the
door and those man you don't see that
very often it's pretty rare
it's very very special family that can
navigate that
all to say is this
be clear about what you're aiming for
and when you aim for it use reality as a
metric
you want a relationship with your dad
great he has to come play
he's got to come play
and he can't play most of the time and
then be abusive just a tiny bit at the
time you can't play most of the time and
then only get high and then come tell
you a bunch of stuff that's going on the
government doesn't want you to know
about
your boundaries are your boundaries they
are what they are and you have a right
to them
make your boundaries firm and strong
hold to them we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
man i'm going with an oldie one of my
favorites of all time off god's record
is so good off the love iron song record
by the one only frank turner song is
called i knew proofrock before he got
famous
i said let's begin at the beginning
we're lovers and we're losers we're
heroes and we're pioneers we're beggars
and we're choosers and we're skirting
around the edges of the ideal
demographic we're almost on the guest
list but we're always stuffing track
stuck in traffic
and i know i'm not the one who's
habitually optimistic but i'm the one
who's got the microphone here so just
remember this
life is about love last minutes in lost
evenings about fire in our bellies and
furtive little feelings and the aching
amplitudes that set our needles all a
flickering and help us with remembering
that the only thing there's left to do
is live we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode our 26
year old son told us last summer
that he's been taking female hormones
for two years
he said that he wants us to call him
rachel
my husband and i have made plans
to visit him in late june
we told him that we have no agenda but
that we love him and we miss him how do
we deal with the name pronoun issue
if calling him rachel and using feminine
pronouns
compromises our values
then how do we open a line of
communication with him and build our
relationship
uh this is yeah so one thank you for
your trust this one's this one's hard